[Musique]
la juge de la cour suprême des etats
unis
bader ginsburg s'est éteinte hier soir à
son domicile de washington
elle était âgée de 87 ans est la doyenne
du plus haut tribunal américain
donc elle est morte des suites d'un
cancer du pancréas elle incarnait le
courant progressiste par la cour suprême
américaine
elle avait été nommée en 1993 par bill
clinton
les experts américains du droit la
décrivent comme juriste est minimaliste
qui bâtit ses jugements sur les
fondements de la jurisprudence
républicains et démocrates mêmes
politiciens canadiens ont salué son
travail et son héritage
donc la mort de cette doyenne la cour
suprême ça rapidement provoqué une
tempête politique hier soir aux etats
unis
j'en parle tout avec raphaël jacob
spécialistes la politique américaine qui
est avec nous justement pour expliquer
les enjeux que ça soulève tout ça
bonjour raphaël bon jour à tout d'abord
pourquoi ce décès de la juge ginsburg
fait autant réagir aux états unis oui
effectivement vous évoquez une tempête
je dirais carrément vous connaissez
caroline j'ai pas l'habitude de faire
dans l'hyperbole là on a à faire et on
va avoir une tempête nucléaire aux états
unis pourquoi d'abord et avant tout
parce que il faut réaliser de nos vivant
on ne jamais jamais vu un siège la cour
suprême irakienne devenir vacant s'y
prête une élection présidentielle en est
maintenant à moins de 50 jours du 3
novembre
deuxièmement vous l'avez mentionné
également en nourriture deux segments
la juge ginsburg est elle seulement la
doyenne la course était également là
leader de l'est le plus à gauche
d'accord on sait que c'est une coquille
âprement diviser la plupart des
décisions majeures des enjeux les plus
controversés de cette cour là depuis des
années tombe avec libertic de 5 à 4 et
là contrairement aux deux premières
domination à effectuer le président
tranche avec le juge coach puis avec le
juge qui a maintenant dans les deux
premières années de sa présidence où il
allait remplacer des juges conservateurs
qui avait été nommé par un président
républicain ronald reagan en
l'occurrence la y est question d'aller
remplacer un juge qui fuit les
applaudissements idéologiquement lui
complètement opposé donc là c'est pain
c'est plus simplement de solidifier
l'allèle conservatrice de la course est
carrément
2 les larges et puis finalement et je
dirais que c'est le plus gros élément de
tous
c'est ce qui s'est passé il ya quatre
ans en 2016 sera qu'on le dit pendant la
dernière campagne présidentielle il y
avait eu un siège qui était devenu
vacant beaucoup plus tôt dans la liste
en février 2016 et barack obama qui
était en fonction à l'époque avait
effectué une nomination à la cause
cette nomination la avait été bloqué par
la majorité républicaine par les
républicains au sénat
on sait qu aux etats unis le sénat a le
pouvoir le devoir fonctionner halle de
confirmer les juges à la cour suprême et
nomination du président et le leader
républicain
hier soir via communiqué annoncé que
cette fois ci le sénat allait voter donc
n'allait pas bloquer la nomination du
président dont elle n'avait pas été
passée il ya quatre ans pour barack
obama mais ce serait possible maintenant
pour donald gens à qui on aurait
vraiment en profiter pour nommer un
autre juge conservateur ce sera un
troisième dans son propre mandat josé
sans fard dans les grandes productions
sans doute eu une juge personnellement
je m'attendrais ce qu'il nomme une femme
dont le conservatrice est effectivement
s'il était capable
si à janvier de faire confirmer cette
juge la prison max est une femme mais en
tous les cas un ou des juges
il s'agirait de trois confirmations
trois juges mise en place à la cour
suprême dans un seul mandat ça ils
reviendront n'a pas vu ça depuis près de
50 ans le dernier président qui était en
mesure de effectué à intel d'avoir un
tel impact sur la cour suprême structure
nexen dans son premier mandat c'est
remarquable et c'est extraordinaire
explosif la pression qui va être mise
sur les sénateurs sur tous les centres
républicain non seulement il y associe
calme je peux me permettre d'ajouter des
soucis qu'il faut réaliser non seulement
avant l'élection du 3 novembre mais
possiblement après l'élection du 3
devant parce qu'il ya une réelle
possibilité que d'autres chambres perdre
cette élection là et puisqu'il quitte
seulement ses fonctions en janvier qu'il
ya beaucoup de pression qu'ils soient
mises dans ce qu'on appelle la période
de transition dont ante élections et
l'arrivée en fonction du nous
vos sénat et possiblement du nouveau
président ce monsieur ben laden est
ténue donc imaginer le climat politique
et les répercussions que ça peut donner
c'est pour ça que c'est si explosive
présente surtout que c'est ça la cour
suprême américaine elles tranchent les
débats les plus litigieux sur les
questions les plus sensibles et l'on
parle d'un pays ultra divisés sur pas
mal de questions justement dont on parle
depuis des semaines et des mois alors on
va suivre tout ça merci beaucoup à faire
pour cette analyse ce matin merci au
revoir